oh how many scripts are you pitched a
week and what was different about this
one yeah not as many not as little as
you might think but if that this one was
episode it was a great story written by
ramin bahrani and a very complex
character to play and after seeing mr.
bronze films and said to be a part of it
you say you like working with writers
and directors because they know what
they want so that how can you tell when
a filmmaker knows what they want what
can you sense in them well they have a
definite point of view that's for sure
and I mean and I were able to talk about
some of what he wanted to do months
before we got out to don't already sure
did last question what do you think
fathers and sons can gain from watching
this relationship on screen I don't know
what they gave watching this I discreet
it I think the film asked more questions
that it has answers fair enough thank
you